hello everyone thank you very much for
inviting me today to
pay the pi data hamburg
um
yeah i have
followed pi data's activities in hamburg
for quite a while but i've never really
took the opportunity to give a talk here
myself so i'm very happy that today is
the day where i will do this
um just a very short introduction about
me i'm um paul i'm a head of uh ai and
data science at data drivers we are a
small it consulting firm in hamburg
and um yeah today i want to talk about
emelops about the concept of envelopes
what it entails what it means
and a little bit about the tools and um
some best practices that i for me
personally have accumulated
um
as i've been working as a data scientist
and
consultant in this field
so i will kick things off with uh yeah
the question what is actually the notion
of mlobs
and in a very straightforward sense you
could say ml ops
is just the combination of machine
learning and devops
um so basically yeah the the the um
the the
the concept or the field of uh training
algorithms based on data
uh finding patterns in data um
combined with uh
um yeah the field of
best practices in software engineering
of automation of
continuous integration continuous
deployment all these concepts
um and that's that's actually part of
the story
and then um you could
think of it in another way um
basically in in kind of a hierarchy of
needs um way
where uh envelopes is
at the top of the the part of the
pyramid
and you would need several layers below
it to make it actually work and to
implement it
so you would need
the traditional devops layer you would
need to
build data pipelines platform automation
and then on top of everything else
you can start building mlaps
and then there is another concept uh
which is very important to ammo ops and
that's uh
that's um that it is
iterative and continuous um and just as
in traditional devops
you have this idea of of continuity of
um iterating upon your software
and trying to make this process as
smooth as possible
so it's kind of the way the similar way
uh how you think about ammo ops
uh uh if you extend this kind of um
you know continuous process
um
i took this uh
visual visualization from
larissa vising garyva
who does a lot of
yeah research and blogging in the field
of mobs and i particularly like this one
because of these three components
that
that are entailed here
and i will briefly just go into each of
them a little bit more in in detail so
we can see what what it is about
so first of all uh in every machine
learning project you have the design
phase
which you can
label as project design
so a very big part of it is the problem
definition
and
usually
yeah this is can be quite a quite a
tricky thing to do because uh what you
aim for is uh to translate some kind of
problem from a real world context
uh into something that is solvable with
machine learning
and if you work as a data scientist in
industry usually you want to solve some
kind of business problem
and
this business problem can be
very very hard to operationalize and
very difficult to put into terms so that
you can actually solve it with
a machine learning algorithm
so that's basically that's definitely
part of the process
and then what follows is that you will
need to have to define some business kpi
which is also very important so for
instance
if you want
to solve a business problem engagement
of people in your
streaming service and you want to
measure this engagement in
something like a click-through rate
so you want to
um you try to make more people click
on on something that you recommend them
and you want to enhance how many times
they click on on something
uh relationship to how often they see it
so that could be a business kpi but
if you train the algorithm
or for instance some recommendation
system algorithm like collaborative
filtering you wouldn't necessarily
optimize your
algorithm itself on
this metric so
there's kind of a challenge to align the
metrics that you will track while
training your algorithm
and the business kpis that in the end
you are trying to manipulate with your
system
and then obviously you have to add
things like data quality checks
and something like a definition of
success
so
that could be something like
enhancing engagement
okay
so let's jump to the second phase
which is labeled as model development
this uh probably is the
the the the face that is
something or is most familiar to people
who
who have data science experience so
uh here we assume we have some kind of
data set that we can
train an algorithm on upon
so we would do things like exploratory
data analysis
we would define some kind of evaluation
scheme
how do we split our data how do we
evaluate the performance of our
algorithms and stuff like that
then we would implement the model and do
training and validation so basically
very standard machine learning steps
and then in the third phase you would
add something
like operations so this is something
very devops oriented
and um
yeah you could you could um
for instance if you if you serve your
model
uh through some kind of api
uh you would necessarily also
apply the same
methods that you would apply to any
other api so you would
monitor the performance of the api
something like
requests per seconds failures
latency times and stuff like that
but obviously on top then you would
monitor things that are specific to
machine learning algorithms
um
for instance data drift so basically
how your
training or prediction data is changing
over time
or also a degradation of your model
performance over time
because once you deploy a model into the
wild or into production
you can assume that many times your data
will be changing
and you will need to retrain your model
at certain times
and then lastly
in this area there's also the field of
automation
so um you will
yeah probably um
consider traditional
devops practices like continuous
integration and deployment
especially if you serve your models
through an api
and then obviously also things like
continuous retraining of your models
yeah one thing to keep in mind is that
automating
the
ml lifecycle is much harder
than automating the the lifecycle of
your traditional
apis or microservices
because many
decisions
are rather soft than very hard so for
instance
if you monitor your model performance
over time
you have to define
certain thresholds yourself and it's not
really
obvious when the system fails or not so
so sometimes there are
humans in the loop needed to to make
certain decisions when model has to be
retrained
but yeah so these are the three main
phases of
envelopes
and
yeah you can kind of conclude that
part of it is solution design so
basically you think about how you solve
some real-world problem
with envelopes
then obviously you
need more development and training the
very basic machine learning or data
science
tools and
things you do as a data scientist
and then you also want to automate these
pipelines you want to serve your model
so that people actually can use it for
something they need it for
and
then what you could also add is that you
want to be able to reproduce your
results
um
and you also want to be able to
experiment and that
yeah relates to the idea that you um
that in in this ammo ops life cycle
you think of
your machine learning system as
something that is continuously improving
and
you would want to try out different
model architectures for instance or
different
feature engineering techniques
and then you want to be able to
reliably
and confidently
decide which model is actually
performing better
and for that you would need to have some
kind of experimentation
tracking implemented
so
in a very rough sense this is kind of
the field or the the
things that the whole
uh yeah
concept of ops and tails
and there is one other um way of of
explaining the concept
that was a coined by noah gift
and he
yeah he he designed this uh
four
field uh
matrix
where um basically um emelops is
described as consisting of of these four
dimensions and
i think that's that's a
pretty um
pretty good way of describing the
concept as well
um
so you not only need the devops part but
you also need some kind of um business
skills especially when it comes to this
question of how do i translate the
business question into something that is
solvable with machine learning
and then obviously you also need the
more fundamental things like data
processing
and
models and algorithms so um that is
actually describing pretty well what
makes uh
ammo ops very difficult because it's
kind of a very multi-disciplinary
skill set that is incorporated into this
field
okay so that was about the notion of
emelops now i was trying to give you an
idea of what components and ammo system
might entail and obviously you can kind
of um
enrich this and make this more
sophisticated and more complex but uh
the thing i was thinking of was what are
the components that every system
like a minimal system should entail
and so i came up with these
six things that you would need if you
want to run machine learning models in
production or a fully fledged ml system
and that's data storage
um for like your training and validation
data
a training environment so you need some
kind of runtime where you can actually
train your algorithm
you would want to have a model registry
where you store your models and where
you can also also version your model so
like for instance if you retrain every
week
uh you want to make sure that you have
like that you keep track of which is the
newest model and things like that
um
then you want to have some kind of
experimentation platform that you can
actually iterate on the performance and
get better and better
you want some kind of serving
environment
where you can actually serve your
predictions to
your users and uh you would need some
kind of monitoring
so again this is very opinionated that's
what i think is um is um
necessary for an lml system
but it's it's definitely not everything
that you could think of
like
um as components that you could add to
the system
but it's like a minimal uh system i
could think of
um so if you look in
how these components would play together
so at the beginning you would have data
storage where your training and
validation data lives
you would then pull that into your
training environment train train an
algorithm
which would then be put into your model
registry
the training environment is linked to
your experimentation platform where you
can keep track
on
about how your training runs were
performing like what kind of setup you
were using what algorithm what hyper
parameters you were using
and then you would
take the model from the registry serve
it
add some monitoring on it
and then
yeah the only thing that you would
probably add as well is some kind of
orchestration of all these components in
the system
yeah so if you feel like uncle roger
here
uh ammo ops is really hard and yeah i
want to go into some aspects that
make it really hard
so
to start with
it's
the ml tooling landscape this is a very
nice way um
of visualizing uh ml tooling it's from i
think from 2020
from a chip huian
um
and what you can see here is basically
like the the areas or the components the
fields in ml in the ml tooling space
things like data pipelines serving model
training
and then you have some sub components
and then i'm gonna just
jump into one of these components which
was a data pipeline and then on the on
the outer
ring you basically see uh companies and
open source
tooling products
for just for the field of data or for
this area of data pipelining
and you get the idea it's like a
huge amount of tooling that exists in
this field
i think she counted something like more
than 200 tooling tools and services that
you can use in the field of uh ml
systems or ammo
and um so yeah it's it's getting really
hard to choose what you use and whatnot
and what suits your um use case best
so yeah that can be very um
uh confusing to choose the right tuning
then obviously something that is very
related to anal ops is the issue of
technical depth
so there's this
yeah very famous almost notorious paper
that came out by google in 2015 about
the hidden technical depth in machine
learning systems
where they were actually um pointing out
that um
yeah what many people have been focusing
on which was mainly the model
development uh you know like
a lot of the the ml hype was um
at that time influenced by
progress made in deep learning and
neural networks and everything so people
were focusing a lot on model
architecture on implementing
state-of-the-art models
and we're kind of a little bit
forgetting about things that are
necessary for the systems to be built
around it and they visualize visualize
this with this um with these boxes so if
you look carefully the black box in the
middle the very tiny one that's the ml
code and then you see all these other
components necessary around it and what
they were trying to highlight is that
if you want to build production-ready
machine learning systems
the code of the model is actually just a
very small bit
but i think there is another fallacy
that you can run into if you try to
build something good in the field of
ammo ops
and that's
what i call over engineering
so it's basically the idea of building
your fully fledged ammo ops platform or
your ml system
for let's say two or three years adding
all the components making it like super
shiny and nice but in the end you're
failing to solve a real world problem
uh so um yeah so that's that's another
part of of the story uh you could also
um kind of highlight it with this uh
tweet which kind of describes it also in
a nice way
uh
um you you aim for something big you are
architecting architecting an nlp model
you're launching beefy gpu instances
um
then you're trying to debug your your um
huge neural network
and find try to find out which layer the
problem is in and in the end you deploy
a five line regex instead so
um
yeah so
what this
actually tells
uh to me or
well what i think is very important to
keep in mind is
that
complex models do not always solve your
your cases uh more efficiently and you
should always be very careful about
deciding where and when to use machine
learning as well
so just uh to summarize this part um i
think
like the the main hurdles of amalops and
what makes it so difficult is that there
are no standards yet so if you look at
the
field of data analytics and modern bi
there's something called the modern data
stack where you have toolings like dbt
for instance uh that are kind of um
uh yeah agreed upon that this is like
the way to to do um data analytics uh
today and and you have some some tooling
that that has been
um yeah shown to be reliable and um that
people
use very frequently
um and there is not
something like this com in in the field
of ammo ops yet
there may be in a few months or years
but yet there is not really something
that
like a go-to solution that you can just
copy and implement
um and
what is very related to this is that
there is this just this confusing
tooling landscape with
essentially a new tool a framework
coming out
almost every week
which makes it very difficult to decide
which is the right tool that fits my
needs
i would also say that there is a high
entry barrier for small teams
so if you don't really have this skill
set and all these these these different
skills in your team that are required it
can be very difficult to to get started
but let's get started anyway as i
promised
i want to show some best practices and i
wanted to show i'll give you an idea of
how i would start and how we for
instance a data drivers also help people
getting started with ammo ops
and um yeah just some best practices um
that i would recommend to everyone
is um
first of all to start where you are so
basically
um
to look at
what are what does my team look like
what kind of skills do i have
um what kind of infrastructure do we use
um
where should we run our ml system on
and things like that and then try to
start from where you are and
continuously develop your system from
there
and
what is also very important i think is
the idea that you want to iterate you
don't want to build the full the fully
fledged system
in one go you want to
try things out and then maybe add a
component and add another one and so on
so you basically
build the system while your
whole
journey with machine learning basically
um
yeah is getting on its way
um you want to balance the four fields i
think that's also very important uh so
not only think about
uh how to build the perfect
system but also think about how to solve
the business problem and try to keep
these both of these things in balance
will actually
yield you pretty good results i think
and then
as a last one beware of the tooling trap
don't go for something fancy and shiny
and new maybe sometimes choose the more
boring and standard but robust and
reliable solution instead
and i also brought you like two small
examples how i would
uh implement like a very minimal ml
system
and the first example i described
as from bi to ai so basically from
business intelligence or data analytics
to ai and you could think of some
company
that
perhaps has a data warehouse already
living
on some kind of cloud platform that
could be aws gcp azure whatever
and they want to
start their journey with machine
learning and want to build a machine
learning system so what you can do then
is for instance use airflow which is
like the boring
and traditional solution for
automation and orchestration but yet the
reliable solution
you could use the cloud storage for your
data storage
you could then
perhaps choose
a cloud managed service that provides
training and serving environments
i think all of the major cloud providers
offer this kind of service where you
basically
can
just
send your training and serving scripts
uh to to the services and they handle
everything
that runs in the background so the whole
infrastructure is handled by
the cloud provider and this is a very
easy start if you don't have
all the skills necessary for running the
heavy load devops
stuff in the background
and what i would add then as like the
only
a little bit more complicated thing
would be
mlflow
which is an open source
software
that
basically allows you to manage the whole
model cycle
so it allows you to track your
training runs and your experiments
and it also provides a model registry so
if you add that you basically have
a
functioning ml system
a very minimal but functioning ml system
and i would say if you
come from this background it's kind of
not that hard to to build it this way
and then i also have like another
example to also illustrate that you
would probably approach the
topic differently if you
have a different background and if you
just do something
different so imagine here you are
like um
some kind of sas company or some kind of
um
company that
runs software as a business
or some kind of web shop
and you probably or the the chances are
very high that you already
have a kubernetes cluster deployed where
your
services are running upon
then you also probably have the skill
set and the people
that are able to manage the cluster
and then you could
for instance aim for something
different
for instance like kubeflow
which is
again an open source
framework that
actually allows you to manage
many components of the ml system so it
provides you um
[Music]
a nice ui that allows you to um
to to manage the pipelines and and the
um
and the the darks or decks like the
whole um yeah the training and the
serving pipelines uh it allows you to
track your experiments uh and it also
provides solutions for serving your
models
uh in the end
so um yeah so i guess that kind of
highlights um
that if
you that um
i would recommend to to look at um
look at
the the point of where you are
if you want to make your moves into um
building your first ml systems
so yeah just to give a quick summary
i would always recommend to start where
you are to iterate and to keep
things simple and stupid
i would look definitely into the field
of open source and i think it's a very
uh very um
again yeah a very very good
solution to use open source tooling
because it's uh it's free to use it
usually has a lot of things implemented
that
other software solutions cannot provide
and
but you should always keep in mind that
the tooling field is kind of
confusing
and then you should focus on the
usefulness of your model and your system
uh and uh yeah you shouldn't try to
build the perfect solution from scratch
if it's not useful then you shouldn't
build it
uh yeah so these are kind of the things
that i would give you at hand and i
think
uh if you take them like as a starting
point um
then uh yeah you can
you can you can start your journey into
the field of ml systems
um uh but yeah as i said earlier it's a
journey and you should enjoy the ride
and you should continuously improve on
your
system and
uh yeah enjoy it
okay so that's kind of the story i
wanted to tell you today uh just like as
a
as a last little uh slide i
wanted to mention that if you want to
meet me or
one of my colleagues we will be at the
datalift summit
in june in berlin
which is organized by the ai guild
there are lots of people from the data
science community giving talks about use
cases and their workshops and everything
so in case you are there please feel
free to reach out
and uh there you we will also have the
chance to um
hear one of my colleagues kai
who will talk a little bit more in depth
about how we
build a transformer model
ml system
on the google cloud platform for
predicting demand
um
yeah at scale and production
yeah so thank you very much for your
attention i'm happy to take any
questions
hey um
uh
i think sauron was the first one who
raised his hands
[Laughter]
thanks again hi paula
hi sir
please excuse my very bad sound and
probably no video or hopefully no video
because i'm
uh looking kind of rough right now but
anyways
you've been
you've been telling us about um much
about this uh life cycle evernote's life
cycle
and you've shown at the end in many or
in the last sketches for in the last
examples as a monitoring
bubble but never mentioned it and
in my experience it is really
really hard to find a solution that
incorporates
pipeline monitoring
infrastructure monitoring and maybe even
kind of monitoring what my my ms system
is is doing right now and how i don't
know um automatic retraining works how
the model performance is is it degrading
or not can you can you
maybe name some examples or what what
your view on this topic is
um yeah so yeah thank you xervan for the
question you uh it's already a pretty uh
tough question i guess um because as you
mentioned correctly um
model monitoring is something very hard
and very difficult um
yeah
i think first of all you would need to
differentiate between the things that
you would want to monitor
as i mentioned um you can monitor
more traditional
things that you would uh
monitor if
for that are
important for every kind of api so you
monitor things like
um requests per second failures latency
and these kind of things but that
obviously all only applies if you have
an online prediction or online serving
kind of framework where you basically
also
receive requests against your endpoint
and your model
if you do like batch serving where you
only serve your model in your
data pipeline and you basically
calculate your predictions
uh in a batch
um
then this would be
different
um and then you can also look at um
monitoring your actual model performance
which is like i would say the most
important thing to do
so you want to monitor
for instance let's say your accuracy of
your classifier
uh and
um as you mentioned it's kind of
difficult to implement because
what you need is not only you to collect
uh um data
uh uh uh uh
you would need to collect all the the
data that is uh um
or the fresh data uh that comes in for
instance uh if when you serve your model
in an online
api
endpoint uh and uh and then kind of um
store your prediction results
and evaluate them so that's a little bit
more effort than um yeah just training
the model
but i would say that uh tracking the the
um the the model performance itself is
already like a really bad big step
towards um monitoring
uh then you could add some more
complexity something like data drift
so you would basically um compare
the the data that
is
collected on your endpoint uh with the
with your training data and then you
would uh kind of
try to estimate how much these um the
data is
different so you would
perhaps look at distributions of your
data uh also like kind of multivariate
distributions and stuff like that
um but
uh i would always start with like the
more simple things uh that are more
important in in the
in the
information chain um so to speak
and uh for instance start with like
monitoring the model performance
kai is will be also we'll be talking
about this in detail um what we did
right now or what we do right now is
just to use
services like cloudwatch or
um
i have
i've forgotten how how the service is
called in the gcp
but there is a similar service that is
yeah that you can use for this kind of
purposes and then we just monitor
the model performance over time and
that's already
difficult enough
thank you
yeah you're
i'm sorry if i pronounce your name wrong
no no no
oh can you hear me
yes
very well
yeah thank you thank you paul awesome
thank you so much um
i i have a lot of challenges because my
team and i
we really are very very short on time so
we do not have the luxury to experiment
a lot on different platforms
or um
we are looking at
this same pipeline
right now and
for code for managing the course side of
things
and then to money
part of me uh paul can you hear
uh you go uh well
it's okay i can i can hear maybe you can
speak a little bit louder than would be
perfect
okay great
can you hear me now
yes
it's better okay yeah it's better yeah
all right so
is it better now
yeah it's way better
okay cool
so um like i was saying earlier i might
see my shot on time so we really do not
have time to experiment a lot
on the different frameworks that we have
so i just wanted to check with you
if this looks like a plan okay so for
code
to manage the code um side of things we
want to use git
right
and then for
to manage data we want to use dvc that's
this open source data version control
for experimentation we want to use ml
flow and then for castration we are
stuck between jenkins
and airflow but because really we're
we're on a low budget uh so
we are trying to not go the way of
stuff like prefect and github action
all right
so um do you think that it looks like a
plan or
we should just rework our ideas what do
you think
yeah uh i think it's it sounds um sounds
like a good plan i i would i would uh
definitely um do
do things very similar and i think none
of these tools i
i wouldn't oppose any of these tools so
i would
definitely use git or gitlab for code
versioning for managing code
using if you want to
use the data versioning 2 i think dbc is
also a good choice and ammo flow is
something that we would use ourselves
um yeah and then in terms of
orchestration my recommendation would be
to use the tool that you um feel more
comfortable with
yeah i presented airflow with something
that is very uh intuitive and easy to
use because
um
that's what i experienced from
our team and our clients that
yeah airflow is very versatile and very
you have a lot of components and you can
build complex tags and everything and
many people know it but if you feel like
that jenkins is
more suitable and that your team knows
it well then yeah you might also go for
that
all right thank you
yeah you're welcome
and good luck with the project
all right thank you so much
nice is there any more questions
no
great um
yeah i would really like to check out
this
this data live submit
um
great uh alex and
[Music]
daphne
yes we're here
i really like our meetup today i think
paul really gave us a lot of nice inputs
yes he did and
i didn't know about a
tube flow or kubeflow i'm not sure how
to pronounce that one right now but this
is the one to check out thanks for that
i know i know flow and i like it
um
but not familiar with the other one
so um
yeah if if that's everything um
thank you everybody for
being here tonight
spending some time learning about
um so many new things
with our speakers
um thank you so much for your time and
um
we will be hosting our next meetup in
two months right
the next one will be in july
yes
cool
and um
if any of you
like to
hang out from time to time with us
don't forget to write
pi data hamburg
to join as a volunteer we are fun people
and we will definitely benefit from
having more local hamburgers
that's funny that's so funny
all right by the way i will stop
recording now
you